foreign
it's kind of low class to just yell at
the top of your lungs I told you so
isn't it
well it's one of your favorite pastimes
so go right ahead
um yeah because I got so much crap from
the Bitcoin Bitcoin Bros
and as George says the Bitcoin Bros are
they're pretty much like Mary case
Bitcoin is pretty much like Mary Kay for
young men you know that's what George
says and he's pretty much right because
they don't they can't listen to anything
their brains are turned off if you're
not going to do their thing oh yeah we
got hit on with crypto and stuff God man
we got just every time I said don't do
crypto I'm an idiot I'm a boomer I'm out
of touch I don't understand and Dave you
ever think you don't like regulation I
would think you don't like I would think
you're like listen I don't like over
regulation when it comes to my money I
do like a wee bit and right now aren't
you wishing you had a wee bit of
Regulation with uh ftx's Sam bankman
fried
I mean there's there's right there in
the name is clue right collapse compared
to Freed I know I know I can't resist
though
the collapse is compared to Enron or
Madoff ftx's failure liking the Enron
scannular Scandal or birdie madoff's
Ponzi scheme uh this from Fox Business
the collapse of cryptocurrency exchange
FTX amid reports that at least one
billion dollars in client funds
disappeared oh my gosh where are The
Regulators well it's not regulated which
some of you were so proud of impacting
potentially around a million customers
has prompted comparisons to some of the
most notorious Financial scandals in
decades yet the magnitude of customers
impacted is even larger FTX which at its
peak was the third largest
cryptocurrency exchange filed for
chapter 11 bankruptcy protection on
Friday Told You So and the company
confirmed over the weekend that millions
of dollars worth of assets were
unaccounted for Told You So the
company's founder Sam bankman Fred
faces allegations that he secretly
transferred that's called stealing up to
10 billion dollars from FTI
[Music]
research amida research Almeida his
hedge fund that also filed for
bankruptcy and the company is facing a
criminal probe in the Bahamas
I mean if you can get the bahamians
upset enough about you that they go
after you because they're pretty laid
back Bunch I'm just saying you get them
pissed off you have really stepped in it
wow man he did some like deep deep deep
deep
like off of the chain and is it man yeah
and it's just greed I mean like that's
like to the deepest deepest core oh this
is this is now this is just thievery
well yeah yes I know but but motivation
of it it's like yeah but anybody that
doesn't get it I mean it's the third
largest Bitcoin exchange Dave I mean
come on at what point Boomer aren't you
gonna wake up to this new and shiny
wonderful thing you you don't know what
you're talking about tell people to stay
away from this you should I've already
made where's your money now uh Mr fried
took it it is funny though because
crypto it was that it was a Hot Topic
even It's Hot Topic today I know but it
but all over the news for the last 48
hours
this may be the biggest fraud and theft
in human history
I mean if it's bigger than Madoff and
it's bigger than this you know the
numbers there uh no it was 68 million or
68 billion or something this is this is
this is they're saying this is going to
be larger yeah yeah it's uh Madoff was
huge though it was massive but um it's
straight up thievery and um and those
millions of people that lost their money
Zippo well sad sad I lost my money on
stupid too
Told You So told you so
oh I'm so I hate that you lost money
guys but I did tell you not to do this
stuff okay I told you well and you can
put a little bit in because I want to be
a little bit of cool
just got a little bit in because I'm a
little bit cool oh my God I mean I got a
friend some multi-millionaire and he
goes Dave I know but I put ten thousand
dollars in I'm like dude you could lose
that on the crap table in 30 seconds and
not miss it I know that's why I did it
and I said now you're going to lose it
on that then you're gonna act like you
were cool see it's just yeah yeah I just
hate the spirit around this stuff and
what it does to people because it gets
sucked into it and then they get their
heads taken off
and um
this guy slow instead he wins the race
predictable Investments that's the
that's the moral of the story there you
go be the tortoise don't be the uh FTX
hair